now you may only see a pile of receipts
but i see a story
[Music]
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
first of all i wanted to start out by
asking jamie this letter you wrote to
michelle where you suggested you run
away together why was that
tell me about that i mean i don't blame
you
well a i'm a big flirt b
duh um b
um
you know truthfully i just was so
excited um to be working with her i i'm
obviously have have watched her work
over the years uh she was the entire
reason i said yes to this strange little
film that they were asking me to be in
um and
i just i'm it i don't even know it's
we laughed about it today we called it
love it first fight um you know like i
you just meet people and you go
i love you let's let's be together for
the rest of our lives and that's how i
feel about michelle then
now everywhere everywhere all at once
all the time
in our universe go ahead michelle what
do you have to say to that
oh my god it's true it was love at first
sight fight like whatever i remember
getting that email because the daniels
wanted to introduce us before we
actually met in simi valley at the irs
building that scary place he thought
maybe it's nice that they say hello
first and what jamie wrote to me was
like let's just ditch the daniels and
run away together and i'm like
i love this girl she's my kind of girl
and it's true every day i rub that
buddha belly
such a joy to work with someone like
jamie who is not just amazing i mean
we've seen all her movies we know how
incredibly talented it was but i never
expected such a generous
loving human being
she brought light and love every day to
the set she was everywhere all at once
with the crew
in front behind everywhere on top below
yeah she is just and she made me
fearless because it was very empowering
you know when you have to do very absurd
you know weird and wacky wonderful
things but still at the same time be so
grounded by a true emotion of love and
heartbreak you know with hanging with
hot dog fingers at the end but that
connection
it was only because
of her
it really was we looked at each other
and
it's not described how we should say
what we should feel but the real
emotions just came came out well i asked
daniels what they thought and i've been
asking all of the casts the most bonkers
day on set just because there had to be
so many daniels talked about you
michelle they said we broke her brain we
think there was one day we broke her
brain was that your wildest day and
jamie for you
you nailed that wrestling move what is
it called the flying kick or the flying
knee
why did you insist on doing it's called
a back breaker
is that what it's called i think it
might be called a back breaker well you
rushed it
thank you michelle what what broke your
brain mommy
no okay i think the day that i just like
was i collapsed on the floor and was
like oh my god after so many years in
the business i can't believe this is
it's come to this it was that buttplug
fight
okay i'm fighting with andy on one hand
and he's trying to take off his pants
and sit on the butt plug and then
suddenly i turn around there's brian his
brother who's like who's like the muscle
man and he's got no pants on and this
butt plug going on with the way i'm
going
it was like oh my god it's like nobody's
ever going to believe that i pulled two
butt plugs out of them oh my god oh my
god yes they broke i was on the ground i
couldn't get up i was just like
yeah it's important though for your
whoever's watching this is going like
what you need to know though at the
center of the whole movie
is this deeply emotional
family
dramaty about a family that's broken and
and through the multiverse
is reattached and so
it's wacky out there for sure but that
there's
what what makes it so satisfying is that
there's
really a deep emotional vein that's
running through the movie predominantly
started with with michelio's performance
so it's fun and it's there's wackiness
and believe me
she does pull two butt plugs out of two
men
and simultaneously
but
she'll also break your heart open
pun intended you just said that
um i wanted to ask you both i mean this
obviously explores the multiverse would
you let's just assume the multiverse
exists would you want to meet a version
of yourself what version of yourself
would you like to meet
requiem
one two three
singer
both want to be singers we both want to
be able to communicate
the art form of singing
would there be which for each of you
because you both had so many iconic
roles which character do you think would
be fun to re-explore in a multi-verse
story where that character gets to meet
a lot of different versions of themself
the truth of the matter is that true
lies helen was sort of kind of went
through her own multiverse when she had
to pretend to be
doris or whatever her name was the the
prostitute that she you know so for me i
think i've sort of done that a little
bit
they even maybe did a little bit in
freaky friday so i kind of feel like i'm
i'm
i'm good with my multiverse world
okay michelle
it feels like i did it all in this movie
okay you've done you babe you never have
to do another you never have to say the
word multiverse again
you have multi the verse
[Laughter]
you should just remove the word from
your vocabulary michelle i wanted to ask
you when you touched on this jamie a
little bit really at the heart of this
there is
you know generate multi-generational
trauma there's a true love story a
mother-daughter relationship that's
really beautiful how did you and
stephanie create that relationship and
why was that so important to you to get
that right and yeah i love you even the
i love you that line that you had to say
to jamie's character was so unforgiving
if you said it wrong the movie wouldn't
have worked it's incredible
no but it's true i think
we truly believed
in
the love
that was we we didn't have to rehearse
it i think all came into this this
movie
believing and wanting it to work out and
the only way it would work out is
because we truly felt it from all every
single character from
stephanie from james from jamie
we all just connected you know sometimes
how the stars align and you don't know
how you can explain it the casting
whoever did the casting
was brilliant because we all just
came together we held each other's hands
and we all just
dove into the bagel and say hell bagel
you know we're everything everywhere all
at once and
it's a very relatable story because we
have we have that miscommunication
i think now especially nowadays with
this big gap with this generation and
the previous generation because this
generation is
has so many things at their fingertips
that goes by so quickly you know when we
watch this film the younger generation
got it
they didn't need any explanation you
know i was very worried about the older
generation jack came like who were in
their 70s and 80s
they were aunties and uncles who wanted
to support our film and i was really
really worried but at the end of the day
first of all they were not offended by
the raunchiness of all the crazy things
that we did and they stepped away saying
okay maybe now i'm beginning to
understand a little bit
of all the things that you all deal with
because this is your generation we
didn't have this even i have problems
multitasking which the new generation
doesn't but what is very important is to
understand that we need to communicate
don't give up on the communication part
because this evelyn wong went to the
ends of the universe and
knew
whatever happens is i'm here and i'm
never gonna go away because this is love
for your family for your daughter or
your father or your husband wow or your
irs auditor oh yes especially the irs
auditor
i'll love your irs auditor or they will
audit you the hell out of you
there's a great
evil spreading about the many verses
and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me fight you i am really good
i don't believe you you are all
astounding for this movie i think you
all should be nominated next year at
next year's awards ceremony you're
amazing um i wanted to jump in and ask
you you play i mean it must be an
actor's dream to play so many different
characters within a film but i'm
wondering if you all now believe in the
multiverse actually existing and if so
what version of yourself do you think is
out there somewhere what would be like
your favorite version of yourself
well i definitely have always believed
in the multiverse i definitely am like
here talking to you but i'm also like
wow
um
i always say that in in in the movie i
would say that my best self would be um
a rock verse in the in the rock first i
think that is the supreme version of
myself but outside of the movie if i
could choose any multiverse dimension i
don't know why i'm saying this i just
feel like i'd be a great carrot like
just like hugged by the soil
just
growing sprouting
healthy
resting
that's amazing that's an image that
might be the better
that was the best well because we
haven't had that question so i really
affirm your question i'm like thank you
oh thank you for me it's really easy
uh i i know the multiverse you know
experience of a lot of imaginations and
and you know what if had i chosen a
different path
but for me uh i you know there's really
something to be said about the present
universe
uh and and i'm you know i haven't done
this in so many years 20 years to be
exact and for me to step in front of the
camera again
uh i like where things are right now i
like where things
may be going i'm really optimistic i'm
really hopeful so i like to still stay
in this present universe for now
okay and what about you james and i want
to get back to that 20 years well i want
to go back to what uh she was saying um
i was sitting there early in the morning
getting made up and almost every day i
see her coming on the on near the
makeup table but she's already but she's
in this funny clothing costumes and i
said well what kind i i was totally
puzzled
at what kind of movie is this she one
day she looks like a clown and the day
she looked like a monster
so i i didn't at that point i was really
confused at what is this movie about
and i would like you i have to see it
again to see what the daniels were
thinking about you know and what the
uh the real values how it twists and
turn in these expression of another
universe you know why do we have to go
to another universe the only way i can
express that is that i think in my
nightmare i begin to understand what the
daniels were trying to do because i have
i think nightmares every night
unfortunately and uh you know all these
things that they say in the film is in
my nightmare and being asian-american i
guess i feel the same way that a lot of
the expression in the movie tells me
that you know this is life and i i hope
to get your opinion as far as the
audience watching what they feel uh
how they identify with the situation
and i always have a hard time making
decisions because i think it changes the
course of my life even if it comes down
to what i'm ordering for dinner but i
wanted to talk about what you said about
a nightmare
for the three of you i'm sure you're put
as actors in these outrageous positions
in this movie you have to totally trust
but what was the most out of control
wtf what is happening in my universe day
on set
i mean well i do want to go first you go
first i mean it's crazy because every
day
i feel like i'm walking onto a different
genre that we're doing you know one day
is an action movie you know the next day
it's a horror movie because we saw
bodies lying around you know the next
universe is like a hot dog universe so
it was just it was just a lot of fun to
see what the daniels cooked up and they
wrote this amazing script you know it
was just a lot of fun to see them
realize what was on the page and and to
put it up on the screen stephanie for
you and i also want to ask like in
addition to that like working with
michelle
having to have those fight scenes with
michelle and create that mother-daughter
relationship because there's a lot of
heart to it as well yeah well i would
say that one of the probably most
logistically challenging uh scenes was
probably the first scene that i shot
with michelle which happened to be the
entrance of jobu scene or the hallway
scene or otherwise known as the elvis
scene blowing up someone's head into
confetti swinging sex toys scene um
because that was our first scene
together which is like crazy you know i
love being weird and i love being weird
with the daniels and we really bring
that out of each other but to do that
and still be rooted in this
very supreme like despair and having it
come having the chaos come from that
place while also like being fearless in
crazy costumes
at michelle yo was a lot of um balls to
juggle and the good thing is that she is
the most generous
scene partner i could possibly have ever
wished for um
but yeah that scene you know as crazy as
it as it is there's a moment at the end
where jobu is kind of telling the
audience or telling evelyn that nothing
matters and it's kind of the supreme
point of that scene and it's actually
also really intimate um
so there's a lot of things happening you
know key i just want to go back to what
you're talking about the fact that i
heard that daniels saw either a gif or
something of you from temple of doom and
said what's that guy up to now and they
approached you what has this whole
experience been like for you your
performance is so amazing what is it
what was it like for you coming back to
acting after all this time
it's really incredible i mean uh
the timing could not be more perfect
it was at a time where i stepped away
for so long and when i saw crazy rich
asians and i had serious fomo and i
called up an agent friend of mine uh and
asked him to represent me uh kind of
begging him pretty much you know and
when i got it two weeks later
unbeknownst to me the daniels was also
thinking about reaching out to me so it
was just kind of like you know this this
thing
and and i you know i read the script and
it was one of the most beautiful script
i've ever read
and the character is just incredible
and to have it
feature a chinese family in a movie like
this where i wish it happened in the
early 80s if we had this project i would
have never stepped away from acting you
know so it's just i'm overwhelmed with
joy i can't believe i'm here
uh and and this is
you know i want to be here i'm really
happy the universe he speaks of
senseless things is so much bigger
than you realize
[Music]
this is obviously
every genre into one it's very
immersive it's about the multiverse i
just want to know about the conception
of these ideas like how did the story
sort of come to the two of you and then
sort of those little moments where when
these characters kind of have to do
these outrageous things
very outrageous things to get you know
their powers how did those ideas also
come to you
yeah so a lot of the sci-fi that we grew
up on was you know like douglas adams
and hitchhiker's guide or kervanagat and
that sci-fi is very funny and playful
and cerebral and and kind of um
doesn't take itself seriously and yet
always finds a way to become profound
and so we knew we wanted if we were
going to be doing a movie about the
multiverse we would want it to do all
those things to touch infinity but also
just not take itself too seriously which
is which is what life really feels like
most of the time anyways it's a weird
mashup of all these contradictions so
like right at the beginning we had this
idea of
doing something
uh statistically improbable that would
like help catapult you to another
universe and
so we just would pitch
what weird action might unlock what
power
and what that fight scene might look
like and that was kind of a
just a fun thought experiment
very early on in the project and we'd
one of our first ideas was like stealing
a kid's ice cream cone
barfing on it
giving it back to the kid and now you
have the power of flight and and that
that was kind of one of the first germs
of the movie but that that's not in the
movie you know so yeah well
that's actually leading me into my next
question because i was going to ask you
are there any multiverses you really
wanted to put in not just the little
actions but multiverses you didn't want
to put in that didn't make it in there
there was one universe where um
everyone's mouths work differently than
ours or communication
because like in our universe right here
as we as we're sitting we communicate
and sound comes out and it's the sound
that is doing the communication right
but in this universe silence would be uh
how you communicate so like uh if you
wanted to talk you would stop making
noise so everyone would constantly just
be going ah
and for some reason
but we imagine that being in a funeral
where everyone's sitting in the audience
is going
right only the person who's giving the
speech is going inside yeah yeah but
that didn't we had too many ideas and
and once we had the character of evelyn
this chinese-american woman trying to
connect with her family it it gave us a
uh a path through our chaotic brains and
and it helped us decide what belonged in
this movie and it was always about what
would what would affect that character
what would uh you know
help her story along um so i can't even
imagine how you begin to edit it seemed
to me like you must have been shooting
for
24 months straight to get all the
footage that you got and ideas i would
never think would ever be either of your
problems you have probably too many
ideas um so now that you are multiverse
experts i know
loki maybe approached you about
directing a series i think there was
like a conflict in your calendar you
were already doing this but do you have
a vision for a movie or a film set in
the multi
verse for marvel
uh
no we're we're so tired of multiverse
the word has lost all meaning to us uh
so we're ready to you know just do like
a regular family drama yeah yeah or like
we have like a like a focused love
triangle idea but uh well small movies
we'll see
yeah famous last words the next one will
be even bigger for somehow we don't know
okay but if marvel approached you to do
a family drama which family or like what
which character would you want to focus
on which one do you think
could get the daniel's treatment yeah it
would be a kaufman a charlie kaufman ask
family drama about uh what's the head of
marvel's name professor xavier no no no
kevin feige yeah yeah it'd be about
kevin feige and his family and like you
know him having dreams where like doctor
strange is trying to help him with his
daughter's college application i hear
kevin feige wants to start acting so i
think this is a good idea yeah okay you
heard it here first so he's playing
himself yeah okay great
what i took from that is who's the head
of marvel that is the brilliant thing
i've ever heard and then i like that his
answer was professor x oh yeah okay well
you know
what was the most out of control day you
would say you had on set because i can't
imagine sort of the direction you get
direction you give these actors or the
set pieces but what personally is your
memory as the most out of control wtf
day on set when when people see the
movie they'll they'll know what the
trophies mean the the trophies are a big
part of the movie and there's a scene
where michelle has to fight uh one of
our choreographers over a trophy and uh
it
we were rehearsing it and her brain just
broke and and she just
couldn't stop laughing for 10 minutes
and shouting like what are you boys
making me do
um we actually had to like take a break
and have her step off set just to like
you know recollect her her brains you
know because i think they fell out like
it's amazing that it took her four or
five weeks before her brain broke but it
did we did finally break her which was
appropriate to the movie we would always
say you know use it your character um
feels that way yeah what kind of
conversations did you have with her like
i know initially everybody's talking
about how jackie chan was the initial
person and then you swapped over but why
was she the person the actress in in
general and then what kind of
conversations like how did you sort of
aside from her reading the script
explain this film and explain it to your
actors yeah so there's obviously no one
like michelle yeo who's had this career
that she has had um and yet
um there's so many parts of her um
her tool bag of talents that you know
haven't been put onto um onto
the american screen yeah american
screens exactly and so um we were just
so excited that she was down and that
she could see the potential in the
script and and um that was a real treat
but the main direction we told her is
like as ridiculous as this movie gets as
immature as this movie gets
everything has to be real everything has
to be grounded you're you're you're in a
cartoon world but you are a real human
being and um that was something that she
did such a good job of every every
single moment you believe
that this is a mother struggling in the
multiverse and she does a beautiful job
but one word answer does everything
matter or does nothing matter please
solve the riddle for us
both oh god i say
nothing matters but that's okay
you